[Music]
in two old news to all for what you
[ __ ] [ __ ] never to all for nothing
for porno making a porno I don't know
some people yeah oh yeah who's that guy
who looks like a purple Jeremy they're
good they're doing it for grandmas now -
oh no Ron Jeremy's penis is still
haven't googled his dick who Ron Jeremy
it's like 10 inches I watched a
documentary on him it's like 10 inches
long when did you watch that documentary
long time ago oh he could count down his
pumps yeah he does 10 down to one and it
can bus yeah crazy he says that he likes
sex and jacking off so much he would
jack off on the way to the porn shoot oh
they don't have it put ron jeremy penis
length gotta take the the parental
controls off it's gonna take up your
whole screen who says ugly guys can't
get laid there's no image i think you
have to watch of porn where he's [ __ ]
somebody really the aint Google Images
there's no yeah nothing the FBI have
been taking it off what happened they
don't let us see dicks no more anyways
this article yeah what is it about this
alright yeah any as a senior dick now to
submitted by Alberto Chan had not child
Oh a sexual harassment case was dropped
cut up in part because the woman was
considered too old to period what did
the judge call it that was too old to be
nobody wife so they were a Courtney she
was like this man grabbed my [ __ ] and
he goes yeah right yeah what kind of
judges that some people like saggy [ __ ]
was this Chinese Court no it's a sixth
place in Italy Oh
so apparently and Italy they have like
this thing about [ __ ] they because
they're saying here that because of a
Catholic Church being brought up or
whatever they always be like women
provoking men and boys will be boys so
the catholic church thinks that girls
are making guys it's girl's fault that
guys are horny well I don't know like I
mean they're just saying like in Italy
because of
that they're kind of seeing it like as
if women are kind of asking for it so
there's a lot of like sexual harassment
so they're me to move minutes for the
guys you provoked me to yeah i stacked
me too I don't want these bullets no but
it seems I mean from what they're
talking about in this article it seems
like a lot of people in Italy like even
the women they're just kind of like oh
shut up about it kind of thing so this
whole thing here is about the the
Italian football federation / former
presidents name Carlota Vecchio and so
he gotta be chill he's like pretty much
like the head honcho of soccer and so
this woman she filed a complaint
accusing him of groping and attempting
to kiss her and she by the way she's a
female I mean she's a soccer executive
named Elizabet tuck or tiny and so she's
accusing of him doing this back in 2015
these are all very nice names so last
year this head set down yeah she's in
her early fifties he looks like an actor
what's his name De Niro he looks like
the Nero and Kevin from shark tank had a
baby yeah I see that's really sad
he had the upside-down smile a frown yes
he's 74 she's in her early fifties and
apparently a prosecutor's in Rome said
that the allegations were likely true
but then they declined to press charges
and like it's just like this big ol
thing and one of the reasons why the
judge dismissed this case is because
he's saying well she's too old to be
harassed but she looks hot for a 50 year
old you saw that yeah she does she look
pretty crusty to me I mean 50 everyone's
crusty I 50/50 that's not bad she was
pretty good for 50 crying her eyes out
that's all she looks like she like
exercises or something I should tell her
tan she doesn't look like she has
plastic surgery that's why I kind of
face her she looks like she sells
Ferraris
one of those classy older late when I
think of Italian Court I think half of
it is mafia guys going it was the big
deal and in the other half is like guys
in togas with the [ __ ] Instagram
reads around their heads like Caesar
Julius Caesar and the you know those
kind of guys in cultures like I think
Olive Garden
mafioso it Little Italy no when's the
last time you guys went back to Olive
Garden
yo we went for the soup and salad but
you had the super salad
I didn't bring on the bread yeah you
don't get like all the dishes you just
get the soup salad and breadsticks yeah
those are fine because they have like
their Italian Wedding soup or whatever
and that's just good but in my mind I
remember it being a lot better right and
so I ordered all the pasta stuff and
this was a couple years ago and I was
like what is this how it tastes it was
it like super salty like is that how
portable yeah I can only imagine it was
like salty and it was like the form of
like Italian food
that's as American night as possible so
everything's in a cream sauce it's very
and so you know it's not bad but I was
kind of like surprises I thought it was
like the bomb mmm that was like the [ __ ]
you know I'm saying yeah I know it was a
little disappointing but that's all I'm
saying gondola seals and saying that's
the best barbecue ever - yeah at some
point I thought it was bomb - but I
loving the seals I'll say this though
their breadsticks are good though yeah
you gotta get the minestrone soup and a
salad and breadsticks that [ __ ] fills me
up all righty their portions aren't big
dude [ __ ] yeah I'm like you get a full
salad full-on soup all this stuff and
then the entree comes out and I'm like I
don't I'm taking that to go
that's another meal chicken parmesan
back to this whole thing though so
they're saying that apparently she made
the allegations too late and that's too
late what factor two limitations two
years three years well I don't know what
it is but they're just saying like all
you made it too late and so now they're
saying that well she that he's in a
public official so therefore she should
have more time to bring allegations
against him and then they are also
saying that she knew him well enough and
that she shouldn't she wouldn't be
afraid of him or intimidated of like by
in this encounter it doesn't make any
God answer you can get assaulted by your
own husband so it's exactly so this she
was saying she said this quote maybe I
am old for them and I could have
defended myself
but I can assure that I felt in a
position of inferior Theory already I
felt afraid because being in that room
meant being in the heart of Italian
football and in that room inferiority
and fear have no age me to Italy version
they're just mainly saying that the lady
that's weird to say you're too old or
too long to know him too well I got that
once I'm saying the court system is a
bunch of guys in togas and [ __ ]
mafioso like who's gonna want this girl
you know like yeah that's what seems
like yeah and then they got some dudes
and togas and they're like I'll drink to
that
I can everyone I mean they're not even
arguing with logic like what kind of a
court system do they have what does it
feel like to be sexually harassed
not as this is a good thing do you want
to find out what are you trying to
understand that Indian guy kissed me
great way oh I'm brain Australia ending
guys just straight rape kiss me how did
that make you feel
he left [ __ ] curry dust on your
[ __ ] cheek I was pretty
flattered oh damn I'm like this
irresistible where you can't control
yourself you want him to do it again
yeah
if you did it again I would take that as
two compliments what if you did it again
then that's three compliments so every
time he did it back to back to back
you'd because well that's called making
out of that I'm like class dog like you
if I told my stop right and he kept
asking is ask what if we didn't have
that option what if you were like some
weak frail man that catonian dude that
was like 6-3 in [ __ ] the rock you
were in a style with the rock and then
he started fingering your booty haul
yeah and a fire you can't really do
anything I didn't mean like as I
physically there's an element of fear
attached to harassment where you feel
like you can't do anything back to them
yeah okay oh that's your turn
yeah so I think it's almost the same
thing as when you're a kid and you're
getting bullied by someone and you feel
like you can't
do anything back to them I know exactly
what it feels like but it's just more
violating yeah sexually violating and
personally versus like that's perfect I
did grab Davis balls it's like I've
already experienced that at church it's
not even Christian she's like a Korean
thing they always Punk like the weaker
ones all the [ __ ] time so like the
younger kids always got harassed
it's hazing yeah its hazing so I just
got hazed again today and I hadn't
remember what that felt like
until today I was like oh my god I feel
like I'm a six-year-old again why do you
think hazing is so strong in like
specifically Japanese and Korean I don't
know those Church memories are the truth
no matter where I went
older kids [ __ ] with the younger kids
all the time because their parents [ __ ]
with the kids and they don't have anyone
else to bully but I will say this though
they did it did create like strong bonds
though oh hell yeah like crazy strong
bond and you actually want to get [ __ ]
to it like if you're if you're that
loser that no one [ __ ] with it's like
you're like the untouchable oh that's
true if you know they were like outcasts
that just didn't even get to hang out at
all cuz the hazing - did it last forever
it was just the initial part they're
testing you to see if you're a little
beat basically yeah that's pretty much
what it is and if you told your mom
you're a [ __ ] and you'll never come
back into the group again
[Music]
Oh